Remember back in lesson two we
learned that a ListView is just
one type of an AdapterView.
Another type of AdapterView
that we looked at was GridView.
So, here we are looking at
the ListView documentation and
in it we see the class hierarchy
diagram for the ListView.
Remember that a tree diagram shows what
class inherits from another class.
And at each level
the code was extended and
then extra code was
added via a subclass.
Now from this diagram we can
verify that the ListView
is a subclass of the AdapterView class.
An AdaptorView has fields and
methods for
a view group whose children
are populated from an adapter and
the ListView can inherit States and
methods from this AdapterView class and
then add on its own code to customize
it for the specific list case.
Let's take a look more closely at
the set on item click Listener method.
So, this method is actually defined
in the AdapterView superclass.
So, let's click into it, and
notice when we dive deeper into it
we jump into the AdapterView
reference page.
So, to reiterate the set
OnItemClickListener was
defined in the AdapterView class.
Now the AdapterView defines the input of
this method to be an OnItemClickListener
object, which is defined
within the AdapterView class.
So, let's click into that.
So, this OnitemClickListener object is
defined within the AdapterView class and
that's why it's referred to as
AdapterView.OnItemClickListerner.